okay hi everyone
so we'll get started again we're now
into um week seven of cs224 n um if
you're following along the syllabus
really closely we actually did a little
bit of a rearrangement in classes and so
today
it's me and i'm going to talk about
co-reference resolution which is another
chance we get to take a deeper dive into
a more linguistic topic they will also
show you a couple of new things for deep
learning models at the same time and
then
the lecture that had previously been
scheduled at this point which was going
to be john on explanation in neural
models is being shifted later
down into
week nine i think it is um but you'll
still get him later um before getting
underway just a couple of announcements
on things
well first of all congratulations on
surviving assignment 5 i hope
i know it was
a bit of a challenge for some of you but
i hope it was a rewarding state of the
art learning experience on the latest in
neural nets
and at any rate you know this was a
brand new assignment that we use for the
first time this year
so we'll really appreciate later on when
we do the second survey getting your
feedback on it
we've been busy reading people's final
project proposals thanks lots of
interesting stuff there our goal is to
get them back to you tomorrow um but you
know as soon as you've had a good
night's sleep after assignment five now
is also a great time to get started
working on your final projects because
there's just not that much time till the
end of quarter
and i particularly want to encourage all
of you to chat to your mentor regularly
go and visit office hours and keep in
touch get advice just talking through
things is a good way to keep you on
track
we also plan to be getting back
assignment for grades later this week
there's sort of the work never stops at
this point so
the next thing for the final project is
the final project milestone um so that
we handed out the details of that last
friday and it's due a week from today um
so the idea of this final project
milestone is really to help keep you on
track and keep things moving towards
having a successful final project so our
hope is that sort of most of what you
write for the final project milestone is
material you can also include in your
final project except for a few
paragraphs of here's exactly where i'm
up to now um so the overall hope is that
doing this in two parts and having a
milestone before the final thing it's
just making you make progress and be on
track for having a successful final
project
um finally um the next class um on
thursday is going to be colin raphael
this is going to be super exciting so
he's going to be talking more about the
very latest in large pre-trained
language models both what some of their
successes are and also
what some of the disconcerting not quite
so good aspects of those models are so
that should be a really good um
interesting lecture when we had him come
and talk to our nlp seminar we had
several hundred people come along
for that
and so for this talk again
we're
asking that you write a reaction
paragraph following the same
instructions as last time um
about what's in this lecture and
someone someone asked in the questions
well what about last thursdays the
answer that is no so the distinction
here is we're only doing the reaction
paragraphs for outside um
guest speakers and although it was great
to have untron boss lou
for last thursday's lecture he's a
postdoc at stanford um so we don't count
him as an outside guest speaker and so
nothing needs to be done for that one so
there are um three classes for which you
need to do it um so there was the one
before from dungeon um colin raphael
which is thursday and then towards the
end of the course um there's euless
vipkov
okay so this is the plan today so in the
first part of it i'm actually going to
spend a bit of time talking about what
co-reference is what different kinds of
reference and language are
and then i'm going to move on and talk
about some of the kind of methods that
people have used for solving
co-reference resolution
now there's um one bug in our
course design which was a lot of years
we've had a whole lecture on doing
convolutional neural nets for language
applications and that slight bug
appeared um
the other day when um danchi talked
about
the
baidaf model because she sort of slipped
in oh there's a character cnn um
representation of words and we hadn't
actually covered that and so that was a
slight oopsie i mean actually for
applications in co-reference as well
people commonly make use of character
level confnets so i wanted to sort of
spend a few minutes sort of doing basics
of confidence for language
the sort of reality here is that um
given that there's no exam week this
year to give people
more time for final projects we sort of
shorten the content by a week this year
and so you're getting a little bit less
of that content
then going on from there um
say some stuff about a state of the art
new york co-reference system and right
at the end talk about um how co-ref is
evaluated and what some of the results
are
yeah so first of all uh what is this
co-reference resolution term that i've
been talking about a lot so co-reference
resolution is meaning to mention to find
all the mentions in a piece of text that
refer to the same entity and sorry
that's a typo it should be in the world
not in the word um so let's make this
concrete so um here's part of a short
story by shruti rao called the star now
i have to make a confession here um
because this um is an nlp class um not a
literature class i crudely made some
cuts to the story to be able to have
relevant parts um appear on my slide in
a decent sized font for illustrating
co-reference so it's not quite the full
original text but um it basically um
is a piece of this story right so what
we're doing in co-reference resolution
is we're working out what people are
mentioned okay so here's a mention of a
person vanaga and here's a mention of
another person akilah
and well mentions don't have to be
people right so the local park that's
also a mention
and then here's akila again
and
akilah's son
and then there's prajwal
um then there's
another son here and then her son
and akash and they both went to
the same school
um and then there's a pre-school
play
and there's prajwal again
um
and
then there's
um a naughty child
lord krishna
and there's some that are a bit
complicated like
the lead role is that a mention it's
sort of more of a functional
specification of something in the play
um
there's akash and it's a tree um i won't
go through the whole thing yet but i
mean in general there are noun phrases
that are mentioning things in the world
and so then what we want to do
for
co-reference resolution is work out
which of these mentions are talking
about the same real world entity so um
if we start off um so there's banaja
um
and
so vanadja is the same person as her
there
and then we can read
through
um she
resigned herself so that's both
bernardjah
um she
bought him a
brown t-shirt and brown trousers then
oops
then she
made a large cut out tree
um she
attached right so all of that's about
the narja
but then
we can
have another person so here's a killer
and here's a killer
um
and maybe those are the only
mentions of aquila so then we can go on
from there
um
okay and so then
there's prajwal
but note that prajwal
note that prajwal is also
aquila's son
so
really aquila's son
is also prajwal
and so an interesting thing here is that
you can get nested syntactic structure
so that we have
um
these sort of noun phrases
so that you know overall we have sort of
this noun phrase akila's son prajwal
which consists of two noun phrases in
opposition
he is prajwal
and then for the noun phrase akilah's
son it sort of breaks down
to itself having an extra possessive
noun phrase in it and then a noun so
that you have achilles
and then this is sun so that you have
these multiple
noun phrases
and so that you can then be sort of
having different parts of this
um be
one person in the co-reference
but this noun phrase here referring to a
different person in the co-reference
okay so back to
um prajwal
um
right so well there's there's some easy
other projects right there's protrol
here
um
and then you've got some more
complicated things so one of the
complicated cases here is that we have
they
went to the same school so that they
there
is what
gets referred to as split antecedents
because
the they refers to both prajwal and
akash
and that's an interesting phenomenon
that and so i could try and
show that somehow i could put
um some splashes in or something and if
i get a different color
akash we have
akash
and her son
and then this one sort of both of them
at once um right so
um human languages have this phenomenon
of split antecedence but you know one of
the things that you should notice um
when we start talking about algorithms
that people use for doing co-reference
resolution is that they make some
simplified assumptions as they how do
they go about treating
the problem and one of the
simplifications
that most algorithms make is
for any noun phrase like this pronoun
they that's trying to work out what is
it co-reference with and the answer is
one thing and so actually
most nlp algorithms for co-reference
resolution just cannot get split and
sequenced might any time it occurs in
the text they guess something and they
always get it wrong so that's the sort
of a bit of a sad state of affairs but
that's the truth of how it is
okay so then going ahead we have akash
here
and then we have another tricky one
so
moving on from there
um we then have this a tree
so
well
in this context of this story
um
akash is going to be the tree so you
could feel
that it was okay to say well this tree
um is also akash um you could also feel
that that's a little bit weird and not
want to do that and i mean actually um
different
people's co-reference data sets um
differ in this so really that you know
that we're predicating an identity
relationship here between akash and the
property of being a tree so do we regard
the tree as the same as akash or not and
people make different decisions there
okay but then going ahead we have here's
akash and she
bought him so that's akash
and then we have akash here
and so then we go on
okay um
so then
if we don't regard
the tree
as the same
as
akash we have a tree here
um but then note that the next place
over here well we have a mention of a
tree
the best tree
but
um
that's sort of really a functional
description of
you know of possible trees
making someone the best tree it's not
really referential to a tree
um
and so it seems like that's not really
co-referent but if we go on there's
definitely
um
more mention of a tree so when she
um she has made the tree
truly the nicest tree or well i'm not
sure is that one co-referent it the it
is definitely referring to our tree and
maybe this one again is a sort of a
functional description that isn't
referring to the tree um
okay um there's different
um
and so
maybe this one though where it's a tree
is referring to the tree
but what i hope to have illustrated from
this is you know
most of the time when we do
co-reference in nlp
we just make it look sort of um
like the conceptual phenomenon
is you know kind of obvious that there's
a mention of sarah and then it says she
and you say ah they're co-referent um
this is easy but if you actually start
looking at real text especially when
you're looking at something like this
that is a piece of literature the the
kind of phenomena you get for
co-reference and overlapping reference
and various other phenomena that i'll um
talk about you know they actually get
pretty complex and it's not you know
there are a lot of hard cases that you
actually have to think about as to what
things you think about as co-referent or
not
okay but
um basically we do want to be able to do
something with co-reference because it's
useful for a lot of things that we'd
like to do in natural language
processing so for one task that we've
already talked about question answering
but equally for other tasks such as
summarization information extraction if
you're doing something like
reading through a piece of text
and you've got a sentence like he was
born in 1961.
um you really want to know who he refers
to to know if this is a good answer to
the question of you know when was barack
obama born or something like that
um it turns out also that it's useful in
machine translation
so
in
most languages
pronouns have features for gender and
number and in quite a lot of languages
um nouns and adjectives also show
features of gender number and case and
so when you're translating a sentence
you want to be
aware of these features and with what is
co-referent as what
to be able to get the translations
correct
so you know if you want to be able to
con work out a translation and know
whether saying alicia likes one because
he's smart or alicia likes one because
she's smart then you have to be
sensitive to co-reference relationships
to be able to choose the right
translation
when people build dialogue systems
dialogue systems also have issues of
co-reference a lot of the time um so you
know if it's sort of book tickets to see
james bond and the system replies
spectra is playing near you at two and
three today well there's actually
co-reference relation oh sorry there's a
reference relation between specter and
james bond because spectra is a james
bond film i'll come back to that one in
a minute um but then it's how many
tickets would you like two tickets for
the showing at three that three is not
just the number three
that three
is then a
co-reference relationship back to the 3
p.m showing that was mentioned
by the agent in the dialogue system so
again to understand these we need to be
understanding the co-reference
relationships
so how now can you go about doing
co-reference so the standard traditional
answer
which i'll present first is co-reference
is done in two steps on the first step
what we do is detect mentions in a piece
of text and that's actually pretty easy
problem
and then in the second step we work out
how to cluster the mentions so as in my
um example from the shruti rao text
basically what you're doing with
co-reference is you're building up these
clusters sets of mentions um that refer
to the same entity in the world
so if we explore a little how we could
do that it's a two-step solution
the first part was detecting the
mentions and so
pretty much
there are three kinds of things
different kinds of noun phrases that can
be mentioned there are pronouns like i
you're it she him and also some
demonstrative pronouns like this and
that and things like that there are
explicitly name things so things like
paris joe biden nike
and then there are
plain noun phrases that describe things
so a dog the big fluffy cat stuck in the
tree and so all of these are things that
we'd like to identify as mentions
and well the straightforward way to
identify these mentions is to use
natural language processing tools
several of which we've talked about
already
so
to work out pronouns we can use what's
called
um
a part of speech taker
i'll change this choice
um we can use a part of speech tagger
which we haven't really explicitly
talked about
but we used when you build dependency
parsers
so that first of all assigns parts of
speech to each word and so that we can
just find the words that are pronouns
for named entities we did talk just a
little bit about named entity
recognizers as a use of sequence models
for neural networks so we can pick out
things like person names and company
names
and then for the ones like the big
fluffy um
a big fluffy dog we could then be sort
of picking out from syntactic structure
noun phrases and regarding them as
descriptions of things
um so that we could use all of these
tools and those would give us basically
our mentions it's a little bit more
subtle than that because it turns out
there are some
noun phrases and things of all of those
kinds which don't actually refer
so that they're not referential in the
world so when you say it is sunny it
doesn't really refer
when you make universal claims like
every student well every student isn't
referring to something you can point to
in the world and more dramatically when
you have no student and making a
negative universal claim it's not
referential to anything
there are also things that you can
describe functionally
which don't have any clear reference
so if i say the best doughnut in the
world that that's a functional claim but
it doesn't necessarily
have reference like if i've established
um that i think a particular kind of
donut is the best doughnut in the world
um i could then say to you um i ate the
the best don't i ate the best doughnut
in the world yesterday and you know what
i mean it might have reference but if i
say something like i'm going around to
all the donut stores trying to find the
best doughnut in the world then it
doesn't have any reference yet it's just
a sort of a functional description i'm
trying to satisfy you also then have
things like quantities a hundred miles
um it's a quantity there's not really
something that has any particular
reference you can mark out a hundred
all sorts of places
um so how do we deal with those things
that aren't really
mentions well one way is we could train
a machine learning classifier to
get rid of those spurious mentions but
actually mostly people don't do that
most commonly um if you're using this
kind of
pipeline model where you use a parser
and a named entity recognizer
you regard everything as you've found as
a candidate mention and then you try and
run your co-ref system and some of them
like those ones hopefully aren't made
co-referent with anything else and so
then you just discard them at the end of
the process
hey chris
yeah um we've got an interesting
question that linguist experience on
this a student asks can we say that it
is sunny has it referring to
the weather
um i think the
yeah so that's so that's a fair question
um
yeah so
people have actually tried to suggest
that when you say it is sunny it means
the weather is sunny
but
i guess the majority opinion at least is
um that isn't plausible
and i mean
for
i guess many of you aren't native
speakers of english but similar
phenomena occur in many other languages
i mean it just intuitively doesn't seem
plausible um when you say
it's sunny or it's raining today that
you're
really saying that as a shortcut for the
weather is raining today it just seems
like really what the case is is english
likes to have something filling the
subject position and when there's
nothing better to fill the subject
position you stick it in there um and
get it's reigning um
and so in general it's believed that you
get this phenomenon of having these
empty dummy it's that appear in various
places i mean another place in which it
seems like you clearly get dummy it's is
that when you have
clauses that are subjects of a verb you
can move them to the end of the sentence
so if you have a sentence where you put
a clause in the subject position
they normally in english sound fairly
awkward
so it's you have a sentence something
like
um
that
cs24n is a lot of work is known by all
students um people don't normally say
that the normal thing to do is to shift
the clause to the end of the sentence
but when you do that you stick in a
dummy it to fill the subject position um
so you say then have it is known by all
students that cs224n is a lot of work
um so that's the general feeling that
this is a dummy yet that doesn't have
any reference
um
okay
there's one more question so if someone
says it is sunny among other things and
we ask how is the weather
okay good point you've got me on that
one right so someone says how is the
weather and you answer it is sunny it
then does seem like the it is in
reference to the weather i'll buy that
well you know i guess um this is what
our co-reference systems are built
trying to do in situations like that
they're making a decision of
co-reference or not and i guess what
you'd want to say in that case is it
seems reasonable to regard this one as
co-referenced that weather that did
appear before it
i mean but that also indicates another
reason to think that in the normal case
it's not co-referent right because
normally pronouns are only used when
their reference is established that
you've referred to uh noun like um
john is answering questions and then you
can say
he types really quickly and it seemed
odd to just sort of start the
conversation by he touched really
quickly because it doesn't have any
established reference whereas that
doesn't seem to be the case it seems
like you can just sort of um start a
conversation um by saying it's raining
really hard today and that doesn't sound
odd at all
okay um
so
i've sort of there
presented the traditional picture
but you know this traditional picture
doesn't mean something that was done
last millennium before you were born i
mean essentially um that was the picture
until about
um that essentially every co-reference
system that was built um use tools like
part of speech taggers ner systems and
parsers to analyze sentences to identify
mentions and to give you features for
co-reference resolution and i'll show a
bit more about that later
but
more recently in our newel systems
people have moved to avoiding
traditional pipeline systems and of
doing one-shot end-to-end um
co-reference resolution systems so if i
skip directly to the
second bullet there's a new generation
of neural systems where you just start
with your sequence of words
and you do the maximally dumb thing you
just say let's take all spans commonly
with some heuristics for efficiency but
you know conceptually all subsequences
of this sentence they might be mentions
let's
feed them in to a new network which will
simultaneously do mention detection and
co-reference resolution end-to-end in
one model and i'll give an example of
that kind of system later in the lecture
okay
is everything good to there and i should
go on
okay um so i'm going to get on to how to
do um
do co-reference resolution systems um
but before i do that i do actually want
to show a little bit more of the the
linguistics of um co-reference because
they're actually
a few more interesting things to
understand and know here i mean when we
say co-reference resolution um we really
confuse together
two linguistic things which are
overlapping but different and so it's
really actually good to understand the
difference between these things so there
are two things that can happen
one
is that you can have
mentions
which are essentially
alone
but happen to
refer to the same entity in the world so
if i have a piece of text
that said barack obama traveled
yesterday to
nebraska obama was there to open a new
meat processing plant or something like
that i've mentioned with barack obama
and obama there are two mentions there
they refer to the same person in the
world they are co-referent so that is
true co-reference but there's a
different but related linguistic concept
called anaphra and anaphora is when you
have a textual dependence of an anaphor
on another term which is the antecedent
and in this case
the meaning of the anaphor is determined
by the antecedent in a textual context
and the canonical case of this is
pronouns so when it's barack obama said
he would sign the bill um he is an
anaphor it's not a word that
independently we can work out what its
meaning is in the world apart from
knowing the vagus feature that it's
referring to something probably male
but in the context of this text
we have that this anaphor
is textually dependent on barack obama
and so then we have an anaphoric
relationship
which
sort of means they um refer to the same
thing in the world and so therefore you
can say i'm their co-referent so the
picture we have is like this right so
for co-reference we have these separate
textual mentions which are basically
standalone which refer to the same thing
in the world whereas in anaphora we
actually have a textual relationship and
you know you essentially have to use
pronouns like he and she in legitimate
ways in which the hearer can reconstruct
the relationship from the text because
they can't work out what he refers to
if that's not there um
and so
that's a fair bit of the distinction but
it's actually a little bit more to
realize because there are more complex
forms of anaphra which
aren't co-reference because you have a
textual dependence
but it's not actually
one of reference and so this comes back
to things like these quantifier noun
phrases um that don't have reference so
when you have sentences like these ones
every dancer twisted her knee well this
her here has an anaphoric dependency on
every dancer or even more clearly with
no dancer twisted her knee the her here
has an anaphoric dependence on no dancer
but um for no dancer twisted her knee
um no dancer isn't referential it's not
referring to anything in the world and
so there's no co-referential
relationship because there's no
reference relationship but there's still
an anaphoric relationship between these
two noun phrases
um
and then
you have this other complex case that
turns up quite a bit where you can have
where the things being talked about
do have reference but an anaphoric
relationship is more subtle than
identity
so you
commonly get constructions like this one
we went to a concert last night the
tickets were really expensive
well the concert and the tickets are two
different things they're not
co-reference co-referential
but in interpreting this sentence what
this really means is the tickets of
tickets to
the tickets to the concert right and so
there's sort of this hidden not
not said
dependence where this is referring back
to the concert and so what we say is
that these
the tickets um
does have an anaphoric dependence on the
concert but they're not co-referential
and so that's referred to as bridging
and aphra
and so overall
there's the simple case and the common
case which is pronominal and aphra
where it's both co-reference and
anaphora you then have
other cases of co-reference such as
every time you see a mention of the
every time the united states is said
it's co-referential with every other
mention of the united states but those
don't have any textual dependence on
each other and then you have textual
dependencies like bridging and aphra
which aren't co-reference
phew
that's probably about us
now i was going to say that's probably
as much linguistics as you wanted to
hear but actually i have one more point
of linguistics um
one or two of you but probably not many
might have been troubled um by the fact
that
the term anaphra as a classical term
um means that you are looking backward
for your antecedent um that the anna
part of anaphra means that you're
looking backward for your antecedent
and in um
sort of classical terminology
you have both anaphora and cataphra and
it's cataphra
where you look forward for your
antecedent cataphra isn't that common
but it does occur
here's a beautiful example of cataphra
so this is from oscar wilde
from the corner of the divan of persian
saddlebags on which he was lying smoking
as was his custom innumerable cigarettes
lord henry watten could just catch the
gleam of a honey sweet and honey cup of
the honey sweet and honey-colored
blossoms of a leburnum okay so in this
example here right the he
and then this his
are actually referring to lord henry
watan
and so
these are both examples of cataphra
in
in modern linguistics um
even though most reference to pronouns
is backwards um we don't
distinguish on
in terms of order and so the term
anaphor and anaphora is used for textual
dependence regardless of whether it's
forward or backwards
okay
a lot of details there
but taking stock of this um so the basic
observation is
um language is interpreted in context
that in general you can't work out the
meaning or reference of things without
looking at the context of the linguistic
utterance so we've seen some simple
examples before
um so for something like word sense
disambiguation
you've if you see just the words the
bank you don't know what it means and
you need to look at a context to get
some sense as to whether it means a
financial institution or the bank of a
river or something like that and so um
a nephron co-reference give us
additional examples where you need to be
doing contextual interpretation of
language
so when you see a pronoun you need to be
looking at the context to see
what it refers to
and so if you think about um text
understanding as a human being does it
reading a story or an article that we
progress through the article from
beginning to end and as we do it we
build up a pretty complex discourse
model in which new
entities are introduced by mentions and
then they're referred back to
and relationships between them are
established and they take actions and
things like that and it sort of seems
like in our head that we sort of build
up a kind of a complex graph like
discourse representation of us of a
piece of text with all these
relationships and so part of that is
these anaphoric relationships and
co-reference that we're talking about
here and indeed in terms of cs224n
the only um kind of whole discourse
meaning that we're going to look at is
looking a bit at an afro and
co-reference but if you want to see more
about higher level natural language
understanding you can get more of this
next quarter
in cs224u
so i want to tell you um a bit about
several different
ways of doing co-reference
so broadly there are four different
kinds of co-reference models
so the traditional old way of doing it
was rule-based systems and um this isn't
the topic of this class and this is
pretty archaic at this point this is
stuff from last millennium but i wanted
to say a little bit about it
because it's actually kind of
interesting as sort of food for thought
as to how far along we are aren't in
solving
you know artificial intelligence and
really being able to understand texts um
then there are sort of classic machine
learning methods of doing it which you
can sort of divide up as mentioned pair
methods mention ranking methods and
really clustering methods and i'm sort
of going to skip the clustering methods
today because most of the work
especially most of the recent work
implicitly makes clusters by using
either mentioned pair or mentioned
ranking methods and so i'm going to talk
about a couple of neural methods for
doing that
okay but first of all let me just tell
you a little bit about
rule-based co-reference so there's a
famous historical algorithm
in nlp for doing
pronoun and afro resolution which is
referred to as the hobbs algorithm
um so everyone just refers to it as the
hobbes algorithm and if you sort of look
up a textbook like giraffsky and
martin's textbook
it's referred to as the hobbs algorithm
but you know actually if you go back to
jerry hobbs that's his picture over
there in the corner um if you actually
go back to his original paper he refers
to it as the naive algorithm
and then his naive algorithm for pronoun
co-reference was this sort of intricate
handwritten set of rules to work out
co-reference so this is the start of the
set of the rules um but there are more
rules or more clauses of these rules for
working out co-reference um and you know
this looks like a hot mess
but the funny thing was that this set of
rules for determining co-reference were
actually pretty good and so
in the sort of 1990s and 2000s decade
even when people were using machine
learning based systems for doing
co-reference they'd hide into those
machine learning based systems that one
of their features was the hobbs
algorithm and that the predictions it
made with a certain weight
was then a feature in making your final
decisions and it's only really in the
last five years that people have moved
away from using the hobbs algorithm let
me give you a little bit of a sense of
how it works okay
so
on the hobbs algorithm here's our
example this is an example from a
guardian book review niall ferguson is
prolific well-paid and a snappy dresser
stephen moss hated him okay so what the
hobbs algorithm does is we start with a
pronoun oops
we start with a pronoun
um and then it says step one go to the
np that's immediately dominating the
pronoun
and then it says go up to the first nprs
call this x
and the path
p
then it says traverse all branches below
x to the left of p
left to right breadth first so then it's
saying to go left to right
for other branches below breadth first
um so that's sort of working down the
tree so we're going down and left to
right and look for um an np
okay and here's an np
but then we have to read more carefully
and say propose as antecedent any np
that has an np or s between it and x
well this np here has no
np or s between npn
and x so this isn't a possible
antecedent so this is all very you know
complex and handwritten but basically he
sort of fit into the clauses of this
kind of a lot of facts about how the
grammar of english works um and so what
this is capturing is if you imagine a
different sentence you know if you
imagine the sentence stephen moss's
um
brother
hated him
well then stephen moss would naturally
be co-referent with him
and in that case well precisely what
you'd have is the noun phrase
um
with
well the noun
brother
and you'd have another noun phrase
inside it um for the stephen moss
and then that would go up to the
sentence so in the case of stephen
moss's brother when you looked at this
noun phrase there would be
an intervening noun phrase before you
got to the node x and therefore
um stephen moss is a possible
and in fact good
antecedent of him and the algorithm
would choose stephen moss but the
algorithm correctly captures when you
have the sentence stephen moss hated him
that him cannot refer to steven moss
okay so um having worked that out it
then says if x is the highest s in the
sentence okay so my x here is definitely
the highest s in the sentence because
i've got the whole sentence what you
should do
is then traverse the pause trees of
previous sentences in the order of
recency so what i shouldn't do now is
sort of work backwards in the text one
sentence at a time
going backwards looking for an
antecedent um and then for each tree
traverse each tree left to right breadth
first so then within each tree i'm doing
the same of going breadth first so sort
of working down and then going left to
right with an equal breadth and so
hidden inside these clauses it's
capturing a lot of the facts of how
co-reference typically works so what you
find
in
english i'll say but in general this is
true of lots of languages
is that there are general preferences
and tendencies for co-reference so a lot
of the time a pronoun will be
co-referent with something in the same
sentence like steven's moss's brother
hated him but it can't be if it's too
close to it so you can't say stephen
moss hated him and have the him be
stephen moss and if you're then looking
for co-reference that's further away
um
the thing it's co-referent with is
normally close by and so that's why you
work backwards through sentences one by
one but then once you're looking within
a particular sentence
the most likely thing it's going to be
co-referent to
is a topical noun phrase and default
topics in english are subjects so by
doing things
breadth first left to right a preferred
antecedent is then a subject and so this
algorithm i won't go through all the
complex clauses five through nine ends
up saying okay um what you should do is
propose nile ferguson as what is
co-referent to him which is the obvious
correct reading in this example
okay
you probably didn't want to know that
and in some sense the details of that um
aren't interesting but what is i think
actually still interesting in 2021
is
what points jerry hobbs was actually um
trying to make um last millennium
um
and the point he was trying to make was
the following so
jerry hobbs wrote this algorithm the
naive algorithm because what he said was
well look if you want to try and crudely
determine co-reference well there are
these
various preferences right there's the
preference for same sentence there's the
preference for recency there's a
preference for topical things like
subject and there are things where you
know if it has gender it has to agree in
gender so there are sort of
strong
constraints of that sort so i can write
an algorithm using my linguistic nouns
which captures all the main
preferences and
actually it works pretty well um doing
that is a pretty strong baseline system
but
what jerry hobbs wanted to argue is um
that this algorithm
just isn't something you should believe
in this isn't a solution to the problem
this is just sort of um
you know making a best guess according
to
um the preferences of what's most likely
without actually understanding what's
going on in the text at all and so
actually um what jerry hobbs wanted to
argue was the so-called hobbs algorithm
now he wasn't a fan of the hobbs
algorithm he was wanting to argue that
the hobbs algorithm is completely
inadequate as the solution to the
problem and the only way we'll actually
make progress in natural language
understanding is by building systems
that actually really understand the text
and this is actually
something that has come to the fore
again
more recently
so the suggestion is that
in general you can't work out
co-reference or pronominal and afro in
particular unless you're really
understanding the meaning of the text
and people look at pairs of examples
like these ones so she poured water from
the pitcher into the cup until it was
full
um so think for just half a moment well
what is it in that example um that is
full
um so
um that what's full there is the cup
um but then if i say she poured water
from the pitcher into the cup until it
was empty
well what's empty
well that's the picture
and the point that um
is being made with these examples is the
only thing that's been changed in these
examples um is um the adjective right
here so these two examples have exactly
the same
grammatical structure so in terms of the
hobbs naive algorithm the hobbes naive
algorithm necessarily
has to predict the same answer for both
of these but that's wrong you just
cannot determine the correct um pronoun
antecedent based on grammatical
preferences of the kind that are used in
the naive algorithm you actually have to
conceptually understand about pictures
and cups and water and full and empty to
be able to choose the right antecedent
here's another famous example that goes
along the same lines
so terry winograd shown here as a young
man
so long long ago terry winograd came to
stanford as the natural language
processing faculty
and terry winograd became disillusioned
with the symbolic ai of those days
and just gave it up all together and he
reinvented himself as being an hci
person and so terry was then essentially
the person who established the hci
program at stanford
but before
he
lost faith in symbolic ai
talked about the co-reference problem
and pointed out a similar pair of
examples here so we have the city
council refused the women a permit
because they feared violence
versus the city council refused the
women a permit because they advocated
violence so again you have this
situation where these two sentences have
identical syntactic structure and they
differ only in the choice of verb here
but
once you add um knowledge common sense
knowledge of how the um human world
works well
what
how this should pretty obviously um be
interpreted that in the first one that
they is referring to the city council
whereas in the second one that they is
referring to the women
and so
coming off of that example of terry
these have been
referred to as winograd schemers
so a winner grad schemer challenge is
sort of choosing the right reference
here and so it's basically just doing
pronominal and aphra
but you know the interesting thing is
people have been interested in you know
what are tests of general intelligence
and one famous general test of
intelligence that i won't talk about now
is the turing test and there's been a
lot of debate about problems with the
turing test and is it good um and so in
particular
hector levesque who's a um a very
well-known senior ai person um he
actually proposed that a better
alternative to the turing test um might
be to do what he then dub winograd
schema
and winograd schema is just solving
pronominal co-reference in cases like
this where you have to have knowledge
about the situation in the world to get
the answer right and so he's basically
arguing that you know you can review
really solving co-reference as solving
artificial intelligence and that's sort
of um what the position that hobbes
wanted to advocate so what he actually
said about his algorithm was that the
naive approach is quite good
computationally speaking it will be a
long time before a semantically based
algorithm is sophisticated enough to
perform as well and these results set a
very high standard for any other
approach to aim for and he was proven
right about that because there was sort
of really talked to around 2015 before
people thought they could do without the
hobbes algorithm
but then he notes yet there is every
reason to pursue a semantically based
approach the naive algorithm does not
work anyone can think of examples where
it fails in these cases it not only
fails it gives no indication that it has
failed and offers no help in finding the
real antecedent
and so i think this is actually still
interesting stuff to think about because
you know really for the kind of machine
learning based co-reference systems that
we're building you know they're not a
hot mess of rules like the hobbs
algorithm but basically they're still
sort of working out statistical
preferences of what patterns are most
likely and choosing the antecedent that
way
they're really um
have exactly the same deficiencies still
that hobbs was talking about right that
they fail in various cases it's easy to
find places where they fail
the algorithms give you no idea when
they fail they're not really
understanding the text
in a way that a human does to determine
the antecedent so we still actually have
a lot more work to do
before we're really doing full
artificial intelligence
but i'd best get on now and actually um
tell you a bit about some co-reference
algorithms um
right so
the simple way of thinking about
co-reference is to say that you're
making just a binary decision about a
reference pair
so if you have your mentions
you can then say well
i've come to my next mention she
i want to work out what it's co-referent
with and i can just look at all of the
mentions that came before it and say is
it co-referent or not and do a binary
decision
so at training time i'll be able to say
i have positive examples assuming i've
got some data labeled for what's correct
to what as to these ones are co-referent
and i've got some negative examples of
these ones are not co-referent and what
i want to do is build a model that
learns to predict co-referent things and
i can do that fairly straightforwardly
in the kind of ways that we have talked
about so i
train with the regular kind of
cross-entropy loss
where i'm now summing over every
pairwise binary decision as to whether
two mentions are co-referent to each
other or not
and so then when i'm at test time um
what i want to do is cluster the
mentions that correspond to the same
entity and i do that by making use of my
pairwise scorer so i can run my pairwise
scorer and it will give a probability or
a score that any two mentions a
co-referent so by picking some threshold
like 0.5 i can add co-reference links
for when the classifier says it's above
the threshold
um and then i do one more step to give
me a clustering i then say okay let's
also make the transitive closure to give
me clusters so it thought that i and she
were co-referent and my and she were
co-referent therefore i also have to
regard i and my as co-referent
and so that's sort of the completion by
transitivity
and so since we always complete by
transitivity note that this algorithm is
very sensitive to making any mistake in
a positive sense because if you make one
mistake for example you say that he and
my a co-referent
then by transitivity all of the mentions
in the sentence become one big cluster
and that they're all co-referent with
each other
that's a workable algorithm and people
have often used it but often people go a
little bit beyond that and prefer um
a mention ranking model so let me just
explain the advantages of that that
normally if you have a long document
where it's ralph nader and he did this
and someone did something to him and we
visited his house and blah blah blah
blah and then somebody voted for nader
because he
in terms of building a co-reference
classifier it seems like it's easy and
reasonable oops
um it's easy and reasonable to be able
to recover this he refers to nader but
in terms of building a classifier for it
to recognize that this he should be
referring to this nader which might be
three paragraphs back seems kind of
unreasonable how you're going to recover
that so those far away ones might be
almost impossible to get correct and so
that suggests that maybe we should have
a different way of
configuring this task so instead of
doing it that way what we should say is
well this he here has various possible
antecedents and our job is to just
choose one of them and that's almost
sufficient
apart from we need to add
one more choice which is well some
mentions won't be co-referent with
anything that proceeds because we're
introducing a new entity into the
discourse so we can add one more
dummy mention
the
n a mentioned so it doesn't refer to
anything previously in the discourse
discourse and then our job at each point
is to do mention ranking to choose which
one of these
she refers to and then at that point
rather than doing
binary yes no classifiers that what we
can do is say aha this is choose one
classification and then we can use the
kind of softmax classifiers that we've
seen at many points previously
okay
so that gets us in business for building
systems and for either of these kind of
models um there are several ways in
which we can build the system we could
use any kind of traditional
machine learning classifier we could use
a simple neural network
we can use more advanced ones with all
of the tools that we've been learning
about more recently let me just quickly
show you um a simple neural network way
of doing that
so this is a model um that um my phd
student um kevin clark did in 2015 so
not that long ago um but what he was
doing was doing co-reference resolution
based on the mentions with a simple feed
forward neural network kind of in some
sense like we did dependency parsing
with a simple feedback neural network so
for
the
mention
it had word embeddings antecedent had
word embeddings there were some
additional features of each of the
mentioner candidate antecedent and then
there were some final additional
features that captured things like
distance away
which you can't see from either the
mention or the candidate and they were
all of those features were just fed into
several feed-forward layers of a neural
network and it gave you a score of are
these things um
co-referent or not and that by itself um
just worked pretty well
um
and i won't say more details about that
um but what i do want to show is sort of
a more advanced
and modern neural co-reference system
but before i do that i want to take a
digression and sort of say a few words
about convolutional neural networks um
so
um the idea of when you apply a
convolutional neural network to language
i.e to sequences
is that what you're going to do
is you're going to compute vectors
features effectively for every possible
word subsequence of a certain length so
that if you have a piece of text like
tentative deal reach to keep government
open you might say i'm going to take
every three words of that i tentative
deal reached deal reached to reach to
keep and i'm going to compute a vector
based on that subsequence of words and
use those computed vectors in my model
by somehow grouping them together
so the canonical
case of convolutional neural networks
is in vision and so if after this next
quarter um you go along to cs231n um
you'll be able to
spend weeks doing convolutional neural
networks for vision and so the idea
there is that you've got these
convolutional filters that you sort of
slide over an image and you compute a
function of each place so the sort of
little red
numbers are showing you what you're
computing but then you'll slide it over
to the next position and fill in this
cell and then you'll slide over the next
position and fill in this cell and then
you'll slide it down and fill in this
cell and so you've got this sort of
little function of a patch which you're
sliding over your image and computing a
convolution which is just
a dot product effectively
that you're then using to get an extra
layer of representation and so by
sliding things over you can pick out
features and you've got a sort of a
feature identifier that runs across
every piece of the image
well for language we've just got a
sequence but you can do basically the
same thing and what you then have is a
1d convolution for text so if here's my
sentence tentative deal reached to keep
the government open that what i can do
is have
so these words have a word
representation which so this is my
vector for each word and then i can have
a filter sometimes called a kernel which
i use for my convolution and what i'm
going to do is slide that down the text
so i can start with it with the first
three words
and then i sort of
treat them as sort of elements i can dot
product and sum and then i can compute a
value as to what they all add up to
which is minus one it turns out
and so then i might have a bias that i
add on and get an updated value if my
bias is plus one
and then i'd run it through a
non-linearity and that will give me a
final value
and then i'll slide my filter down and
i'd work out
a computation for this window of three
words and take 0.5 times 3 plus 0.2
times 1 etc and that comes out as this
value
i add the bias
i put it i'm going to put it through my
non-linearity and then i keep on
sliding down and i'll do the next three
words
and keep on going down and so that gives
me a 1d convolution and computes a
representation of the text
you might have noticed in the previous
example that i started here with seven
words but because i wanted to have a
window of three for my convolution the
end result is that things shrunk so on
the output i only had five things that's
not necessarily desirable so commonly
people will deal with that
with padding so if i put padding on both
sides i can then start my three by three
convolution my three sorry not three by
three my three convolution i'm here and
compute this one and then slide it down
one and compute this one and so now my
output is the same size as my real input
and so that's a convolution with padding
okay so that was the start of things but
you know how you get more power with the
convolutional network is you don't only
have one filter you have several filters
so if i have three filters each of which
will have their own bias non-linearity i
can then get
a three-dimensional representation
coming out the end and sort of you can
think of these as conceptually computing
different features
of your text
okay so that gives us a kind of a sort
of a new feature re-representation of
our text
but commonly
we then want to somehow summarize what
we have
and a very common way of summarizing
what we have is to then do pooling
so
um
if we sort of think of these features as
detecting different things in the text
so you know they might even be high
level features like you know
does this um
show signs of toxicity or hate speech um
is there
reference to something so if you want to
be interesting does it occur anywhere in
the text what people often then do as a
max pooling operation where for each
feature they simply sort of compute the
maximum value it ever achieved in any
position as you went through the text
and say that this vector ends up as the
sentence representation
sometimes for other purposes rather than
max pooling people use average pooling
where you take the averages of the
different vectors um to get the sentence
representation then general max pooling
has been found to be more successful and
that's kind of because if you think of
it as feature detectors that are wanting
to detect was this present somewhere
then
you know something like positive
sentiment isn't going to be present in
every three-word um sub-sequence you
choose because they're somewhere there
and so often max pooling works better
um and so that's
a very quick look at convolutional
neural networks except to say this
example was doing 1d convolutions with
words but a very commonplace that
convolutional neural networks being used
in natural language is actually using
them with characters and so
what you can do is you can do
convolutions over subsequences of the
characters in the same way
and if you do that this allows you to
computer representation to any sequence
of characters so you don't have any
problems with being out of vocabulary or
anything like that because for any
sequence of characters you just compute
your convolutional representation and
max pool work and so quite commonly
people use
a character convolution to give a
representation of words perhaps as the
only representation of words but
otherwise is something that you use in
addition um to a word vector and so on
both by def and the model i'm about to
show that at the base level it makes use
of both a word vector representation
that we saw right at the beginning of
the text and a character level
convolutional representation of the
words
okay with that said i now want to show
you before time runs out i'm an
end-to-end neural co-references model so
the model i'm going to show you is
kenton lee's one from um so done
university of washington 2017.
this is no longer the state of the art
i'll mention the state of the art at the
end but this was the first model
that really said get rid of all of that
old stuff of having pipelines and
mentioned detection first just build one
end-to-end big model that does
everything and returns co-reference so
it's a good one to show
so
compared to the earlier simple thing i
saw
we're now going to process the text with
biostms
we're going to make use of attention and
we're going to do all of mention
detection co-reference in one step
end-to-end and the way it does that is
by considering
every
span of the text up to a certain length
as a candidate mentioned and just
figures out a representation for it and
whether it's co-referent to other things
so what we do at the start is we start
with the sequence of words and we
calculate from those
uh
standard word embedding and a character
level cnn's embedding
we then feed those as inputs
into a bi-directional lstm of the kind
that we saw quite a lot of before
but then after this what we do is we
compute
representations for spans
so when we have a sequence of words um
we're then going to work out a
representation of a sequence of words
which we can then put into our
co-reference model
um so that we
i can't fully illustrate in this picture
but so
see subsequences of different lengths so
like general general electric general
electric said um will all have a span
representation which i've only shown a
subset of them
in green so how are those computed well
the way they're computed is that the
span representation
is a vector that concatenates several
vectors and it consists of four parts it
consists of the representation that was
computed
for the start
of
the span from the
um by lstm the representation for the
end from the bio stm that's over here
and then it has a third part that's kind
of interesting this is an
intention-based representation that
calculate is calculated from the whole
span but particularly sort of looks for
the head of a span and then there are
still a few additional features um so it
turns out that you know some of these
additional things um like length and so
on is still a bit useful
um so
to work out the
the
final part is not the beginning and the
end what's done is to calculate an
attention weighted average of the word
embeddings so what you're doing is
you're taking the x-star representation
of the final word of the span
and you're feeding that into a neural
network to get attention scores
for
every word in the span
which are these three and that's giving
you an attention distribution as we've
seen previously
and then you're calculating the third
component of this as an attention
weighted
sum
of
of the different words in the span and
so therefore you've got the sort of a
sort of a soft average of the
representations of the words of the span
okay um
so then once you've got that
um
what you're doing is then feeding these
representations
into having
scores for whether spans are co-referent
mentions
um so you have a representation of uh
the two spans
um
you have a score that's calculated for
whether two different spans look
co-referent and that overall you're
getting a score for r different spans
looking co-referent or not
um and so this model is just run end to
end on all stands now it sort of would
get intractable if you scored literally
every standalone piece of text so they
do some pruning they sort of only allow
spans up to a certain maximum size they
only consider
pairs of spans that aren't too distant
from each other etc etc but basically
it's in sort of an approximation to just
a complete comparison of spans and this
turns into a very effective co-reference
resolution algorithm today it's not the
best co-reference resolution algorithm
um because maybe not surprisingly like
everything else that we've been dealing
with
there's now been these transformer
models like burt have come along and
that they produce even better results so
the best
co-reference systems now have you make
use of bert
in particular
when dante spoke she briefly mentioned
spanbert which was a variant of bird
which constructs
blanks out for reconstruction
subsequences of words rather than just a
single word and span bird has actually
proven to be very effective
for doing co-reference perhaps because
you can blink out whole mentions
people have also gotten gains actually
funnily by treating co-ref as a
question-answering task so effectively
you can find a mention
like
he or
the person and say what is its
antecedent and get a question answering
answer and that's a good way to do
co-reference
so if we put that together um as time is
running out um let me just sort of give
you some
sense of how results come out for
co-reference systems
so i'm skipping a bit actually that you
can find in the slides which is how
co-references
scored
but essentially it's scored on a
clustering metric so a perfect
clustering will give you a hundred
and
something that makes no correct
decisions
would give you zero
and so this is sort of how
the co-reference numbers have been
panning out
so
back in 2010 actually this was a
stanford system this was a
state-of-the-art system for co-reference
it won a competition it was actually a
non-machine learning
model because again we wanted to prove
how these rule-based methods and
practice work kind of well um and so its
accuracy was around 55 for english 50
for chinese
then gradually
machine learning this was sort of
statistical machine learning models got
a bit better
wiseman was the very first neural
co-reference system and that gave some
gains um here's a system that kevin
clark and i did which gave a little bit
further gains um so lee is the model
um that i've just shown you as the
end-to-end model and it got um a bit of
further gains but then again you know
what gave the huge um breakthrough just
like question answering was that the use
of span bert
so once we moved to here we're now using
span bird that's giving you about an
extra 10 or so
um the co-ref qa technique proved to be
useful um and then the very latest best
results are effectively combining
together span bert and
a larger version of spanbert and co-fqa
and getting up to 83.
so you might think from that that co-ref
is
sort of doing
really well and is getting close to
solved like other nlp tasks um well it's
certainly true that in neural times the
results have been getting way way better
than they had been before but i would
caution you
that these results that i just showed
were on a corpus called onto nodes which
is mainly newswire and it turns out that
newswire co-reference um is pretty easy
i mean in particular there's a lot of
mention of the same entities right so
the newspaper articles are full of
mentions of the united states and china
and leaders of the different countries
and it's sort of very easy to work out
what they're co-referent to and so the
co-reference scores
are fairly high
whereas if what you do
is take something like a page of
dialogue from a novel and feed that into
a system and say okay do the
co-reference correctly you'll find
pretty rapidly um that the performance
of the models is much more modest um if
you'd like to try out a co-reference
system for yourself um there are
pointers um to a couple of them um here
um where
the top one's ours from certain um kevin
clark's new co reference um and this is
one that goes with the hugging face
repository that we've mentioned
you